kovy jabs in the classroom this is the
next step in the vaccine rollout to
immunize the nation
from today more than 3 million 12 to 15
year olds became eligible to have an
injection
parental consent is being sought but
children can overrule if they're deemed
competent i'm happy i've got it because
it makes it easier to go out and enjoy
myself now i've got grandparents i'd
love to be safe around them and spend
time with them and be safe it wasn't too
bad
and after what has been a success to
vaccinate millions of adults across
britain the scientific community was
split when it came to children
it's really important to remember that
the uk chief medical officers have
supported the introduction of the
vaccine to this age group and that's
then been signed off by government and
we're doing it we're rolling it out in
schools because it is our best chance
not just to protect children but to
protect families as well and those
reassurances may be needed to many more
parents soon today health regulatory
bodies receive data from pfizer
suggesting their vaccine offers a robust
immune response to children aged between
5 and 11. we started off with small
numbers of children looking at different
doses to make sure that we got this
right
so i i was not particularly surprised
but very pleased with the outcome i
think we've got the right dose that
essentially reduces the potential to
have common reactions and provides a
level of antibody that's likely to be
protective
but there were mixed feelings amongst
some parents we spoke to you just never
know what the effect would be
until it's more test then i'll say no
for now i mean i've had the vaccine
myself but it's it's early days for for
kids and i just don't think they need it
my husband and i have had the vaccine
our older children have had the vaccine
so i don't see you know as long as it
keeps them safe then i'm quite happy for
them to have it
there will now be a push for the vaccine
to be approved for primary school
children the argument is it will help
stop outbreaks and keep kids in
classrooms
another big step in expanding our
inoculation drive may not be far off in
zaman rashid sky news